hello
i'm dr scott evans i'm a professor of
neuroscience and genetics at the albert
einstein college of medicine
and i'm going to tell you today about
research that my group has been carrying
out
together with my colleague david hall at
einstein
on the nervous system of a tiny worm a
tiny nematode worm uh known as
cenorabidis elegans or c elegans for
short
what we have done is we've determined
the connect home of the
uh part of the nervous system in the
male worm that guides the male's mating
behavior
now by connectome we refer to
uh
the sum total of all the synaptic
connections in a nervous system
uh so as we know
uh
the the
brain is an enormous connection a
network of neurons neurons are connected
together in circuits and we need to
know what those circuits are to
understand how the brain functions now
uh the obama's brain initiative uh has
been uh begun to try and
advance our understanding in basic ways
about how the brain functions and and
one of the important aspects that they
emphasize is uh
the concept of mapping they talk about
mapping at several levels at the level
the cellular and molecular level uh
showing
gene expression patterns across the
brain uh activity uh mapping showing how
different parts of the brain
are active and we heard about that
activity mapping from raphael houston
another lecture in this series yesterday
uh third level is that of connectivity
and that's what i'm going to be talking
about this is the physical connections
between the neurons that create the
circuits in the brain
and then we have the level of functional
mapping to showing which
functions are mapped to different
regions of the brain and finally
conceptual uh mapping of trying to
understand how our minds and our
consciousness our memory behavior emerge
from our brains
so as i said uh
the
the emphasis what i'm going to talk
about mapping level is that at the level
of connectivity synaptic connectivity of
the neurons
so
the circuits in the brain are connected
by by synapses between the neurons
and to create a map of these synapses
and
define the circuits
we need to use the technique of electron
microscopy
now this is because synapses being
sub-cellular structures are smaller than
the wavelength of light they're below
the resolution of a light microscope and
we have to use an electro microscope to
observe them
uh
unfortunately the em technique is is
inadequate to map a large structure such
as the brain to give you an idea uh what
that challenge would be like imagine uh
the continent of europe or say the
entire united states uh covered surface
covered with little circles about an
inch in diameter three centimeters in
diameter circles covering the entire
surface of the united states and your
job is to map these little circles
unfortunately you can't see them the
only way to see these circles is with a
special camera so you get this camera
and you start to use and you find this
camera takes pictures that are only one
yard or one meter on the side so you
have these one square meter picture so
you have to cover the entire
united states the lower 48 states the
continent of europe
with these one square meter pictures and
then you have to analyze each one we'll
have about a thousand of these little
circles in it you have to name each one
then you have to connect one circle to
another across the
different images uh you would have eight
trillion of these photographs of the
surface so this is the tiny size of an
electron micrograph compared to the size
of our brain would be comparable to this
problem
so uh how what how can we proceed to
find the circuits in our brain so uh
again in use uh raphael youth's lecture
he quoted the famous english molecular
biologist sydney brenner saying that
science advances uh in in steps first
technology improvements uh improving
experimental observations and finally in
theory and he said probably in that
order and uh
the
brain initiative uh emphasizes the
improvement in techniques and
technologies that's going to be
necessary to determine the structure and
function of the brain
so in my analogy of mapping these little
circles in the united states you could
for example get a bigger camera that
takes a bigger picture than one square
meter
and people are taking this approach to
the electric microscopy
trying to make bigger em images and
rapid uh computerized methods for
analyzing them
it's ironic actually the brenner would
mention these three
approaches to advancement because he's
actually famous for taking what is
really a fourth approach
when
we're faced
with a problem intractable problem like
mapping the circuits in the brain this
has happened over and over again in
biology with an intractable problem
we approach it by trying to find
the same phenomena but in a much simpler
format smaller and simpler format
and this is what a brenner did by
choosing the nematode worm for analysis
of the function of the nervous system
so c elegans uh is a millimeter long
uh grows on petri plates it eats
bacteria in the labs very inexpensive
research
there are two sexes
a male and a female the female makes her
own sperm so she's functionally
hermaphrodite so we refer to her as a
hermaphrodite
now the maphrite nervous system has 302
neurons in it
and the male has 383 neurons and we know
these numbers very precisely because a
remarkable feature of these nematode
worms is that they they're cellularly
identical from individual to individual
each individual is made up of the same
cells same number of neurons same number
of gut cells skin cells muscles and so
forth precisely the same and these can
be mapped out and
in fact uh the connections in this small
nervous system can be determined by
electromicroscopy so it was in the 19
late 1960s that brenner who had been
already famous for work on the genetic
code
looked around as i said for a simple
model system where he could tackle the
major problems of the nervous system
and he wanted to use a genetic approach
which had been shown to be so powerful
in in deciphering the genetic code and c
elegans was very
good for genetics
and you wanted to determine the complete
synaptic connectivity by serial suction
electromicroscopy and then you wanted to
study how this circuitry functions and
how it's formed and and what is the
genetic basis for formation so two major
problems
how does the nervous system work
and how is the nervous system built
now since uh
brenner selected the worm for study the
field has grown uh in in dramatic ways
and and gone in all directions of
biology some of the most important uh
discoveries in c elegans in fact are at
the level of cell biology uh and
the uh the
power of c elegans as an experimental
system arises primarily because of this
tiny size so let me re just re-emphasize
that um comparing the worm to the size
of your brain so here's a cross-section
through your neocortex showing the six
layers of the neocortex and some
pyramidal neurons uh two to four
millimeters uh thick
here's the size of c elegans millimeter
long
here's the region of the nervous system
that we have determined the connectivity
of the neurons in and this little square
is the size of the electromicrographs
that we have to use so you can see that
that
is tiny size compared to the enormous
size of the brain and you need something
as small as the elegance to use this
approach to at this at this point in
time uh define synaptic connections in
the nervous system
so one might reasonably ask
given the tiny size of the worm and the
simple number of neurons in this nervous
system can this possibly be
a reasonable model for understanding
something like our brain
and
in fact
c elegans are very typical animal and
its nervous system does what all animal
nervous systems do
it takes sensory input from the
environment
it evaluates that information to make a
decision and the worm has to decide what
should i do
and then finally having made that
decision it has to execute the motor
program for that output whether
locomotion or turning or mating um
and so this is what
all nervous systems do they're input
output devices
which make computations
and the the information that c elegans
has for guiding his behavior uh come
from environmental cues it has many
sensory neurons facing the environment
has sensory neurons facing its internal
physiology it has
evaluates whether it's hungry or hot and
so forth
it
takes sensory information from its past
experience a worm will remember where it
lasts found food in terms of temperature
and salt
and remembers those parameters and will
seek food by returning to those
values
motivational state the worm has various
needs at different times
to eat uh to stay cool uh to mate and so
all of this information is
brought together in the nervous system
and then uh
has
used to make a decision and to guide
sets of behaviors
it has the same
motivated purposeful behaviors as all
animals the elegance it has to find food
has to stay safe it has to disperse it
has to reproduce
so finding food it will chemotax towards
food it can detect chemical gradients
and as i said it will remember we're at
last found food um
for staying safe that may be not be so
so straightforward and i'm going to show
you some movies of worm behavior um here
for example you will see c elegans uh
being devoured by a predacious nematode
bigger than itself so go ahead tracy run
that movie
ouch
all right in the next uh movie um
a worm
c elegans worm encounters a buffer that
has previously had pristiance in it go
ahead uh uh tracy run the next movie
that went a little bit quick you missed
the first uh backup but you you see the
worm is uh repelled by uh the buffer
that normally would like to swim in
uh
next uh there's more than predatory
nematodes that would like to eat c
elegans there are fungi uh and so um
watch here this fungus makes little
lariats that trap worms okay go tracy go
ahead run that one
the worm goes through the lariat the
lariat constricts and the worm is caught
and is digested now worms know about uh
this as well
uh so
here you'll see a worm
in in this uh
uh next movie you'll see a worm
approach the lariat right here worms
have uh light sense such sensors in
their heads that can detect that they're
run through this lariat and they back up
and they have a behavioral um inhibition
uh that prevents them from wagging their
head as they back up and so they can
slip out of these lariats go ahead tracy
next one
it swims away to live another day
so that's uh staying safe in your
environment
for dispersal
the
worms have a dispersal stage called the
dower
which is desiccation resistant arrest uh
development does not feed
and uh dowers have a specific behavior
called nictating behavior in which they
climb up on
things and they can even climb up in
towers of each other and they stand on
their tails and wave their heads go
ahead tracy run this movie
okay uh there's another species of
nematode that uh doesn't wait for a
passing insect they the dowers are
standing on their tails waving their
heads so they get picked up by a passing
uh insect and they get dispersed that
way uh there's a um
another nematode species
uh called uh steiner nema
that
doesn't wait for a passing insect now
watch this movie where the little red
arrow is go ahead and
play the movie
tracy
okay play it once more that goes kind of
quick
all right if you want to know where that
worm went you have to use a uh a
high-speed camera
and
in the uh
this the next movie
uh
watch this
what happens here go ahead tracy
they jump
finally uh for um
for uh
reproduction now i'll show you a movie
uh one panel looks like this it has a
male with two mating partners uh on a
bacterial lawn on an auger surface and
this male with mating partners will
sometimes mate but most of the time just
wander around the lawn but it will never
leave the lawn
and then in the other panel you'll see a
male alone
and a male alone will not stay on this
bacterial lawn it makes excursions off
the lawn and eventually takes off so
male with mates will always stay with
them and never leave the food whereas a
male alone will leave food in order to
find mates play the movie tracy
so
a male uh is not happy if it's not with
mates
um
so
uh
the uh
it's important so male the worm has all
of these complex behaviors just like all
animals do uh
and
in fact it's important to to know that
uh its nervous system is very similar to
ours in in many ways and uh
it's
the common ancestor of worms and humans
must have had a rather advanced nervous
system because a large portion of the
genes uh is conserved from worms to
humans
uh their universal mechanisms and cell
biology have been discovered in worms
like rnai and micro rna program cell
deaths uh the components of the nervous
system are the same use the same
proteins neurotransmitters
neuromodulators receptors channels
synaptic components so dopamine
acetylcholine serotonin all of these
things there are neuropeptides
oxytocin for example is a neuropeptide
that governs our social and sexual
behaviors and it's required for the
males to express that mate searching
behavior which i just showed you
so
it's reasonable suppose that
by studying the circus so all these
molecular components arose in the common
ancestor of worms and humans that's why
they're the same in the two
and so by studying the circuits in cl
gans
we may be able to gain insight into the
nature of the ancestral circuitry
in which these molecular components of
our nervous system evolves so uh
with confidence that
c elegans is going to tell us something
important about
our nervous system uh brenner um
undertook to determine the uh his group
his research group john white in
particular to to
determine the connectivity in the cl
against nervous system so first a little
primer about the c elegans nervous
system on the top the hermaphrodite on
the bottom the male
there's a nerve ring in the head
which is more or less the brain of the
worm
there's a ventral nerve cord and then a
small ganglion in the tail
and in the male this posterior ganglion
is is much more uh is much larger and
more complex and this is the region of
the nervous system that we have
determined the connectivity for
so the
electromicroscope is used to
determine the connections in this
nervous system
here we look at a cross section through
the posterior of the nerve ring and one
of these electromicrographs is shown
here there's the cuticle of the worm
body wall muscles the pharynx which in
muscular structure which pumps in the
bacteria for feeding
and here's the ventral ganglion
here's a blow up of that
region you can see what a large
proportion of the worms body in fact is
made up of its nervous system now here
you're seeing on the right the
cross-sections of the neurons
and here we are at higher magnification
of what this looks like in the electron
microscope
so here are synaptic densities that we
use to score
the presence of synapses there's another
one presynaptic density synaptic
vesicles
here i showed you at the very same
magnification a bit of hippocampal
nervous system section with the em and
it's remarkable how similar the cl
against nervous system is to mammalian
nervous system here we see the synaptic
densities uh synaptic vesicles the sizes
the cross sections of the neurites are
similar
and as i said this seems quite
remarkable that you can almost hardly
tell them apart
so
uh in 13 years of effort uh brenner's
group uh led by john white uh determined
the connections
in the nervous system of the mafordite 5
000 chemical synapses 2 000
neuromuscular junctions 600 gap
junctions
and they published this in 1986 and uh
taking up an entire 350 page volume of
the philosophical transactions of the
royal society
there's
a page in this uh volume for each neuron
and lists of synapses and representative
em showing the synapses and the location
of the of each neuron uh for all the 302
neurons of the hermaphrodite
this has been absolute bible for c
elegans research has been the foundation
for neuroscience research highly
productive uh since that time um there's
you'll sometimes hear that we've known
the connections in the client's nervous
system uh for over 20 years and we still
don't understand how the nervous system
works so it's not very important to get
the connectivity this is really
quite a misconception uh
some of the connections in the hematite
connection were immediately
interpretable uh
the
locomotion circuit we could help from
the motor neurons however went forward
how it went backwards uh command into
neurons that determine the switch
between forward and backward locomotion
the circuits
from by which the worm responds to light
touch to go forward and back with these
were all immediately interpretable
and now to be sure there are many other
parts of this complex circuit that can't
be immediately uh interpreted but that
doesn't mean it's not important to have
it they
are what you need to then go forward
further with experimental work guided by
the known connectivity to determine
how it works
so
about
10 years ago
dave hall and i decided it was time to
get more connect homes now the brenner
group tried to computerize the process
of determining the connectivity uh but
computers were too small
and slow at the time they were doing
this work they're way ahead of the time
and so they did their reconstruction
from
paper prints analogous to those prints i
mentioned those across the united states
uh but in this case they're
can you can cover a worm
marking the paper prints with colored
pens and writing down all the synapses
so an enormous effort and that's why it
took so long and because of that effort
no one attempted to do this uh in an
intervening time but meanwhile computers
have come along and so we thought how
can we reapproach the problem of getting
more cell against connectomes in
particular we wanted the connectome of
the male knowing the male had a complex
behavior and a complex region of its
nervous system different from the
hermaphrodite so um i'll show you the
mating behavior of a male
worm
in a movie and
if you look at the panel on the right
what you're going to see in the movie is
this series of steps where the male
responds to contact backs up while
pressing its tail against the
hermaphrodite turns around the
hermaphrodite and it's trying to locate
the vulva
it has hardness structures called
spicules inside that it's going to
vibrate as soon as it detects the vulva
and is trying to insert those spicules
into the vulva when it achieves that
it will transfer sperm and the sperm
will go into the aphrodite where they
fertilize the democratized eggs
and then the male will swim away so
tracy can we have that movie
okay so i hope you can see those various
steps that i mentioned uh it's a
multi-step behavioral pathway uh not all
of those steps need to be taken by the
male if the encounters the vulva
immediately it immediately responds and
tries to insert its spicules so um
this is uh the input output behavior the
input through sensory neurons that the
male is using to detect its location on
the maphronite it has to make a decision
what where am i on the map right what
should i do should i make a turn should
i insert my specules uh am i ready to
transfer sperm this is the input output
function the the behavioral pathway
that
we want to understand how the nervous
system
creates this
so
the
male has specialized
sensory neurons uh in uh in its tail
that guides this process uh there are
structures sensory structures that
extend from the the body called rays
uh each ray has two endings of two
sensory neurons in it uh there's stencil
around the cloaca called post cloacals
and psyllium and the hook
and then the spicules themselves have
sensory neurons inside that detect when
the spicules are inserted into the
hematite vulva altogether 52 sensory
neurons in 25 sincilla in the male tail
that guide this process so that's the
input function uh the output
is
the guidance of these various muscle
groups that
are arranged to create the behavior
so there are body well muscles which are
present in hematite as well but those
are engaged by the male to
locomote and hold its body during mating
then there are
specialized male muscles only found in
the male called diagonal muscles which
would cause the the body to curl
and then there are a set of male
specific sex muscles around the cloaca
that hold and open the cloaca and and
control the spicules uh and uh bringing
them in and out
uh altogether 64 muscles 24 shared uh
with the hermaphrodite and 40 which are
male specific
uh so here just to give you an
impression of how these muscles work
here the the despicable retractors and
protractors which make the spickles go
out like that
in and out just give an example of how
these sex specific muscles work
so
the cambridge group the brenner group
had made an attempt to determine the
connectome of the male
and they completed the reconstruction of
a number of neurons
but
they didn't finish and we had the
micrographs from their effort available
to us and our job was to see how could
we use a computer to make it simpler to
analyze
these micrographs very quickly so
we designed a program which we call
elegance
which allows us to make manual
annotations of the micrographs now
ideally we would like someday a computer
and to do the human brain a computer is
going to have to analyze these images
but computers not only in brenner's day
but even to this day cannot decipher the
way we can uh these electron micrographs
so we knew we had to do manual
annotations uh but we wanted to make it
uh quick and easy so uh what we do is we
load
side by side successive serial sections
of electromicrographs on the computer
screen
and these are digitized images of the
electromicrographs
worked on in the 1970s uh by donna
albertson and others in the uh the
brenner group in cambridge uk
and they so the numbers the color
numbers you see are the numbers they
wrote on the micrographs to try and
trace through where the neurons are but
what we do is uh we uh mark a single
point with a mouse in the center of each
neurite so there's one profile there's
another one there's another one and then
we tell the program which ones are
connected across the series of sections
the stack of sections uh from one uh
image to the next so those green arrows
show that then we also mouse click onto
the synapses there's one there here at
higher magnification you see
the presynaptic density there's one
there one there uh one at this point the
blue arrow so we enter those and enter
which cells are presynaptic and which
one's postsynaptic finally all these
mouse clicks go into a database and our
software creates the maps and synapse
lists in other words we generate the
connectome this way
by
staring at these mouse clicks staring at
these monographs and putting in the
mouse clicks it took two people
about two years a year or two year to
complete the reconstruction of the
posterior male circuits
so these circuits consist of 144 neurons
81 specific to the male 63 are shared
with the hermaphrodite
there are 64 muscles
40 specific to the male and 24 shared
3 800 chemical synapses 1000
neuromuscular junctions 3 500 gap
junctions
here's an example of of one of the
neurons is a pdb motor neuron
it's present in both sexes in fact
here's the cell body in the posterior
region and it runs a
branch around to an axon around to the
dorsal side for innervating dorsal
muscles here's the same neuron
reconstructed from the
electromicrographs in the male
here's the cell body and you can see
that the male this neuron is highly
sexually dimorphic it has grown out a
large extra uh set of branches
in which you have intermingled chemical
input uh chemical output and gap
junctions and a big mess of synapses and
a bunch of branches this is a typical of
the neurons in in the male ganglion
they are branchy and a notable feature
is this intermingling of input and
output
there's no clear separation of dendrite
and axon in this uh
in this neuron
and that means that there's no trigger
zone these are graded potential neurons
they don't have action potentials uh
these are typical of
c elegans and many other invertebrates
and
neurons in your retina there are many
neurons which are analog devices rather
than digital devices the cl against
nervous system is an analog device
and
you have intermingled input and output
and graded potential uh firing of these
neurons
another feature here you can see is that
this is a motor neuron but it's uh also
got output onto other neurons so it's in
in a way acting as an interneuron so
it's an inter motor neuron and this
mixed character is also very typical of
cl against neurons
all right so here we are in the sum
total of 3 200 connected cell pairs all
together in the connectome and we can
display this like this and it's pretty
bewildering
uh so
what are we going to do to try and find
circuits are there circuits that
discernible what are the functions of
individual neurons we're faced with this
issue after we had completed the the
connectivity and so
one thing we did was we turned to a
mathematical approach
we used uh graph theory which is a field
of mathematics that studies the
properties of networks so we have a
complex network interconnected neurons
and muscles
and there's a large
field very large field of study of the
properties of network so we took
advantage of that a little bit of mass
so you can follow
in the field of graph theory
a graph
consists of two sets what's called the
graph not what we normally think of as a
graph with two axes and a line but in in
mathematics
a graph is is
consists of two sets it comes from set
theory um a set of vertices um and edges
uh and then uh sorry so two sets uh
instead of vertices
there they are v1 v2 v3 a
a bunch of vertices or nodes
and then
a set of edges and each edge consists of
pairs of vertices 1 3 1 7 2 3 and so
forth
that's what a mathematical graph is
there's two ways that this can be these
sets can be represented one is as a
network like this so here you see the
nodes and the edges the nodes the
vertices are the neurons or muscles in
our nervous system
the edges can be of two types that can
be directed they go in a certain
direction they represent um the synapses
and directed edges in particular are
chemical synapses or rectifying gap
junctions if they if there are any
rectifying gap junctions we don't know
and then there may be undirected edges
if which represent gouge functions that
are not rectifying so this is one way
that our graph can be represented and
it's a typical way we draw a network
but this is a second way in a very
important way
a graph can be represented as an
adjacency matrix so
two
vertices that are linked by an edge in
the network are said to be adjacent in
the network
and
so here's
the
matrix of those adjacencies
here's the pairs of vertices on the
horizontal and vertical axes
uh this is a directed graph a directed
graph of the chemical synapses so on
this side we have the presynaptic
neurons on the top we have the
postsynaptic neurons
now
you can see here that this already is
showing us some details and patterns
which we couldn't see in that first
representation i showed you of this
hairball network that if you just
arrange the
nodes randomly and connect them with
lines you get a hairy mess here we're
starting to see some order uh and this
is our task to in in deciphering how
this network functions is to order the
nodes and vertices and group them in
such ways that we can start to see the
patterns of their connectivity so
how have these been ordered they've been
ordered in hierarchical
fashion so he needs the sensory neurons
these are the interneurons the motor
neurons and these are the muscles so
they're going down uh the the
the the hierarchy of the information
flow from input to output uh and that's
already helped us arrange uh to see some
patterns we arrange the sensory neurons
in single since together muscles in
single groups together and we start to
see these patterns
now if we look at the jc matrix at a
higher
magnification we can see that each of
these connections
has a number
as low as 1
as high as here's 172 it goes one to 100
these represent the strengths of the
connections between the neuron on the
left and the neuron at the top
how do we get these strengths
these represent the number of serial
sections this is a physical size of
these connections
the number of serial sections in the
electromagnets are we can do this in the
worm as a proxy for
synapse size the estimate of synapse
size because we have a worm the neurons
are running in the ap direction and as
they go along they make opposant
synapses here you see presynaptic
density and synaptic vesicles now our
serial sections are transverse to the
worm and so by simply counting up the
number of serial sections traversed by
synapses uh
we can get a number for the physical
size of the connection and so this is uh
gives us a proxy for the strength of the
connection we don't know
how
what the activity of these connections
is we don't know whether excitatory or
inhibitory so we don't know the sign of
the
of the connection uh but it's a first
estimate for the strength it's the
morphological strength and so here uh
these are called the weights of the
edges each edge has a value and a weight
and
as i said we don't know whether the sign
on these weights is plus or minus
excitatory inhibitory but it's the first
pass at determining the strengths of the
connections first estimate and
this numerical quantitative adjacent
matrix is the form of the graph that
mathem mathematics can take hold of can
uh work with this um and so there are
many algorithms and and
approaches uh analyses to understanding
properties of these networks based on
the jc metrics and we took advantage of
them one in particular
was we asked whether the graph was
modular
so modularity in a graph or communities
in the graph are are partitions of a
network or graph
where each of those communities contains
more connections between the vertices in
that community then those vertices are
connected to the vertices in other
communities and there are algorithms
available to to partition and find an
optimal partitioning of a network
in this way and we took advantage of
those and found that in fact the mail
network is highly modular
and in fact the mathematics looking only
at the amount of connections between the
neurons and muscles knowing nothing
about the biology
gave us five modules that fit the
biology beautifully
so for example uh here the first module
we call the response module uh has a
subset of the ray neurons which we knew
from experimental work triggered the
male to respond to the mapredite and
start to back up
and
those
ray neurons interface onto interneurons
which then interfaced onto the motor
system so the second module grouped the
command interneurons the motor neurons
body wall muscles all together to drive
the worm forward and backward
and we call that the locomotion model
module
two modules appear to be uh for uh
holding the worms posture as it mates uh
and uh
why am i not advancing
uh
oh there we go um
so uh one
of these modules contains those diagonal
muscles i mentioned and a different
subset of ray neurons which innervate
those and that would cause the
the tail to curl
another module has output onto the
dorsal and ventral body law muscles but
not through the locomotion circuit so we
think that also is for um
holding the posture of the worm and then
finally the last module is we call the
insemination module because it has the
neurons and muscles around the cloaca
and holding the spicules and
it has
neurons which have output onto the gonad
there's the cell body and the synapses
and this looks like it's the set of
neurons and muscles that will be gauged
once the vulva is located so the
response module is before the volvo is
located and the insemination module
takes over
once the valve is located
so using these modularity we can now
start to arrange the graph
in a more orderly and understandable
fashion so here
we have the
four of the five modules i left out one
of the of the posture modules and from
top to bottom on the right
the
neurons and muscles are organized
by modules so there's the response
module
there's the locomotion module
there's the posture one of the posture
modules there's the insemination module
and within the modules of we've grouped
neurons of like function into single
node so all the rays in the response
module or all the
the neurons in the insemination module
the sensory neurons and examination
module are grouped together that
simplifies the picture and then
everything is arranged left to right by
its output so first we have sensory
neurons at the top and organs at the
bottom
and
two types of interneurons emerge from
this analysis a set of interneurons that
impinge on the
output on the the end organs and a sense
a set of interneurons uh that impinge on
the first layer of interneuron so we
have a layered multi-layered structure
largely feed forward and we can see the
flow of information from sensory input
to motor output in this highly now
simplified and more clearly
understandable diagram of the uh of the
system now the brain carries out
some types of computations far faster
more robustly and with far less energy
consumption than a digital computer and
and this has been known uh for a long
time and it's been known that the brain
is a highly
massively parallel structure and so
theorists have looked at properties of
those kind of parallel networks to try
and understand uh
how it is that our brain can function so
efficiently and so robustly
and
speed and efficiency it can be explained
by short pathways
and highly interconnected neurons
and
we see these features in our circuits so
um these are additional properties of
the network the graph theory can can
give us for example
how many edges do we have to traverse
from one neuron to the next in the
network the average minimum path length
in the male mating circuits is just
three
so you can get from any neuron to any
other neuron they're all cross-connected
to each other by a small number of steps
another feature of a network that can be
analyzed is called the clustering
coefficient
this is the probability that if two
neurons are connected to a third that
they're going to be connected to each
other and so that value is about 0.3 for
our network so it's 30 chance that if
a and b are connected to c that a and b
are going to be connected to each other
and these properties average minimum
small minimum path length
a small average minimum path length and
high clustering coefficient
is a property of many networks and these
are called small world networks this is
a small world phenomenon with six
degrees of separation between people in
a social network uh the
small world
small world networks have short path
lengths uh suggesting rapid
communication across the network
they have high clustering coefficient
that suggests local computational units
or motifs that are functioning within
the network
so uh
speed and efficiency in a small world
network uh robustness fault tolerance
you can delete edges and or nodes from a
network
in the field they like to say that the
performance of the network degrades
gracefully as you remove vertices and
edges and this certainly is true of
nervous systems as well
and this property can be explained by
having multiple parallel pathways and
extensions extensive divergent and
convergent connectivity so for example
so divergent connectivity if a single
neuron
innervates two different neurons uh and
convergent connectivity two neurons
innervate the same
downstream neuron
and we see this extensively in the male
circus uh and to illustrate these points
of parallel uh
connections um
and short path lengths i i show you the
circuits that uh innervate one set of
muscles these eight political muscles
two
uh
four pairs a gubernacular erector and
gubernacular retractor
which do this
they raise a structure over the cloaca
and the anterior and posterior obliques
which function like this
all right these neurons these muscles
are innervated by the sensory neurons in
the post cloacal syncillament here i
show you just one the pca the a-type
post-glycosinsilum on the left side has
a cell body where you see it
a
sensory ending by the cloaca cell body
here
a region where it's making lots of
synapses
this
shows the connection of those eight
muscles by all the neurons of the post
glycosylum now
this is a
a
graph or network diagram of the
connectivity these don't represent cell
bodies and axons this is just the cell
looks like you see at the left
this is a schematic representation
and shows you that the muscles are
connected in a single synaptic step by
the sensory neuron so here are the very
short pathways in the circuit
and here is the value uh in number of
serial sections by which each of those
muscles is innervated by the neurons now
you see each neuron is innervating
several muscles and each muscle is
receiving input from several neurons so
there's
convergent and divergent connectivity in
this group
i got to the end of that set hold
on okay
so
there are additional connections that
will unify the function of this group
the muscles are connected together by
gap junctions as you see here
and
the sensory neurons are highly
cross-connected to each other
so all these cross-connections are going
to make this uh
function as a unit and coordinate its
activity so in a way the the output of
the system is built into this
connectivity so by all this
cross-connectivity we're going to have
the neurons reinforcing each other the
sensory neurons reinforcing each other's
output by having
output onto other sensory neurons and to
make a robust signal that will activate
this set of muscles in a uniform way
so a large fraction of the input into
muscles is directly from sensory neurons
the pathway through very short reflex
pathways guiding the male's quick
reflexes during mating
so
what about interneurons what do they do
if sensory neurons are innovating
muscles well they don't only innervate
muscles uh for example the pca the a
type neuron and the post colloidal since
27 of its output is on to an interneuron
a male specific interneuron called pbx
which has output onto the body while
motor system now pca also has output
onto a set of interneurons called cp
neurons and these have output onto the
pvx so the cp neurons are in the
mid the top layer of interneurons and
the pvx is in the second layer towards
the output end that i showed you earlier
and this
creates a
motif that is known in the field motif
field as a feed forward loop and this
occurs very frequently in our circuits
and also the very commonly found in
natural circuits uh natural networks is
found in the human brain
here's another example of a feed forward
loop where we have
the circuits that are uh in the
insemination module here's the
post-glycem sensory neurons
the collective muscles i've been talking
about uh here's a innervation of the
gonad by a postcard neuron your body
wall muscles are part of this we think
the body contracts during insemination
during ejaculation
now all of these muscles also receive
input from this this set of cp uh
neurons
uh
which also receive input from all of the
uh of the sensory neurons so this is a
tremendously convergent and divergent uh
connectivity all of the
end organs will receive some input from
all of the of the sensory neurons via
this cp
interneuron in this feed forward loop
so there's there's a the cell bodies of
the cp neurons and this is where they're
making uh synapses onto the uh to the
gonad so there are two types of feed
forward loops theoretically there's a
so-called coherent feed-forward loop and
which the signs of the two pathways are
the same and then an incoherent loop
where we get a change of sign we think
our fee for loops are all of the
coherent type uh because it wouldn't
make sense for
all these neurons are focusing on
promoting the same activity and here's
another example
where the ray sensory neurons innervate
a ddy interneuron and also via lua
rene garcia has shown that if you remove
the lua interneuron from this loop the
males mate perfectly normally until you
tap the plate and then they get
disrupted and swim away so
it looks like a normal male is resistant
to outside disturbance while it's mating
and the function of these lua feed
forward loop would be to reinforce the
output of pvy stimulated by the ray
sensor neurons and keep this pathway
going probably as
as a coherent feed forward loop
this kind of connectivity as i mentioned
is highly overrepresented in many
natural networks
uh so
network features that help explain
network function short pathways highly
interconnected neurons repeated small
motifs and feed forward loops robustness
is highly fault hard because there are
so many multiple parallel pathways with
convergent and divergent connectivity
now
the theorists have
analyzed the properties of artificial
neural networks to try and understand
how the brain can function and uh two
types of theoretical
artificial neural networks have been
studied extensively one is called
perceptron introduced by rosenblatt in
1962.
it's a layered feed-forward network just
like our network with an input layer an
output layer an intermediate layer and
these can be used to
detect patterns if the weights are set
properly between the input and output
nodes uh the
the output you can get a certain output
depending on different inputs
by this neural network
another type
was introduced by hufffield who pointed
out that if you have feedback in the
circuit as well then you get a so-called
attractor network that will have
self-reinforcing behavioral states
and will eventually fall into certain
patterns of connectivity of output that
are reinforced and hopfield pointed out
this is like having a memory stored in
the network
now
to get certain memories or certain input
output function in a perceptron one has
to the theorists have to figure out what
weights to put between the vertices or
between the nodes
and so they have learning algorithms
they have training sets that teach and
iteratively adjust the weights
to get the kind of performance they're
looking for now when we teach or when we
train we gain knowledge and so the
weights of the network can in a way be
considered the knowledge that the
network has of its environment or what
it should do
so the weights in the structural jc
matrix
that we've determined represent some of
the worms knowledge
about its environment
and it's a fascinating way to think
about it this knowledge is encoded in
the genome
these are
genetically specified network
connections these are innate behaviors
in the worm
and
so
there are genes in the genome that
determine the weights of all these
connections and we don't really know
what those genes are there are many
candidates but we basically have no idea
how the jc matrix is encoded in the
genome
the learning algorithms in our case must
have been natural selection over many
many generations of course
and connectivity and and has behavior
can evolve by gradual changes in the
weights of the connection something
we'll be able to understand when we know
how the connections are specified to
begin with so just to re-emphasize this
point this complex pattern of
connections with specific weights is
genetically specified in some unknown
way it's a major exciting problem for us
to think about in the future how this
can be specified
so
we would like to compute behavior how
the network is specified of course is
the problem of how is it built that
render posed initially the other
question is how does it work
and we would could say that we
understand how it works
if we could compute behavior so we know
the set of inputs we know the worm's
internal state it's motivational state
we can
predict exactly what its output would be
that would be really understanding
behavior
and
the structural connectome that i've
described is a first step towards this
goal but it's only a first step uh for
reverse engineering the network uh we
need the functional connectome uh we
have a static structure but of course
the network the nervous system of the
dynamic structure we need the signs of
the weights we need whether excitatory
or inhibitory
we need really the functional strength
not just the morphological size
and we need to know how the activity can
be modulated as the network functions
the neurons change synaptic weights
change as over time as the network
functions we need to know what the
hidden edges are what i call hidden
edges there are connections between
neurons which we can't see in the
physical structure because they occur
independently of synapses so these are
trans-synaptic so these are our
extrasynaptic
hormonal for example or neuropeptide
signaling that occurs between cells that
are not necessarily connected by synapse
we have to know what those are
so the structural connectome tells us
what neurons can communicate over a
short time scale so i don't mean to
imply that it doesn't have any use in
understanding behavior at all
the extra synaptic connective
communication is much slower than a worm
mating
typically and so the quick reactions uh
can only go over the structural
connectome and this restricts how we can
think about how this much worse works uh
greatly
so fortunately we can get the additional
information we need from experiments uh
we can do calcium imaging and voltage
sensitive imaging to observe the neurons
functioning we can perturb the neurons
by celebrations
we can block and activate uh
neurotransmission experimentally
we can
activate cells by optigenetic tools
experimentally and then of course we can
use genetics to determine the components
that are important
so finally to summarize uh we have a
second connectome
it's the first structural description of
a natural neural network with measured
weights i didn't emphasize that in the
earlier hermaphrodite reconstruction
weights were not measured with the
precision that we've been able to do it
using our computerized approach
uh computer assistance has brought
determination of new connectomes within
reach
and the measured weights
make a mathematical analysis possible
and even with the nervous system
consisting of a few hundred neurons
mathematical analysis was necessary to
decipher network structure
so a whole new aspect of the phenotype
is now available to us is extremely
exciting the further improvements in
methodology going on in a number of
connectomics laboratories uh for
connecting long unbroken series of
sections more rapid large-scale
electromicroscopy as i mentioned earlier
uh computer analysis of micrographs is
going to absolutely be necessary to do
larger structures all these techniques
are being worked on developed rapidly
and under the brain initiative will be
pursued
extensively
and so with these new methods we're
looking forward to new cell against
connectomes we want to do the male head
which in fact we have completed the male
head and the comparison of the two sexes
shows that in the head the
the circus are essentially the same
between the two sexes although there are
some male specific connections we want
to look at how the connectivity develops
during larval development we want to be
able to analyze the connectivity by
mutants or after learning or
environmental influences to see if the
environment can change the conductivity
of the worm and finally other animals
are now coming within each other
nematode species we can look at
evolution of connectivity other small
animals the sound of the sea squirts
being worked on at dalhousie university
zebrafish drosophila
and finally small parts of larger
nervous systems like the retina and
someday although it's still very large a
cortical column of parts of our own
nervous system
so it's an exciting time uh where we're
we're starting to see an aspect of the
nervous system which is essential to
know to understand how the circuits
function
and we're going to see new information
coming out
very soon
in this area of
neuroscience so with that i would like
to acknowledge the people that
contributed to the work in my lab and to
this talk the
movies were provided by a number of
laboratories and i want to acknowledge
the c elegans research community is a
tremendously
cooperative exciting group of people
that we share our materials and it's
been just a spectacular group of people
to work with in a career in science
images and graphics from worm atlas uh
chris crocker and the einstein graphics
department elector mike graf from the
cambridge group donna albertson uh ken
nguyen nicole thompson
uh image registration by hurt wetzel and
greg hood at the research
super computing center software was
initially made by meta helix life
sciences and then developed by mung shu
in my laboratory extensively and then
finally the connections were the
micrographs were scored by travis gerald
yee wong and analyzed by adam loniar's
christopher britton
stephen cook
of course my collaborator david hall has
been part of this project
and finally for support
software development was initially
funded by nih but the connectomics
project itself
was funded by the g harold and lila y
may there's charitable foundation and
they should receive tremendous
recognition for their support of this uh
of this project uh thank you um
i think uh
i've really uh run uh my full hour but
they tell me i can take a few more
minutes for uh q a so let me look at uh
uh the questions and see
if there are some uh if every
individual's connect homes are different
are there certain common patterns across
connections if yes what do
uh i don't see the rest of the question
oh here we go are there soon
it's just what does that imply i don't
know if you're talking about every
individual human or every individual
worm um
the
worm connectomes are not different worms
connectivity in the worm nervous system
is uh quite consistent and stereotyped
and
but of course in humans there will be
differences and but
are there going to be common patterns
absolutely for example this motif that i
mentioned the feed for motif is
something that recurs
in
in nervous system so hopefully the
problem of getting the human connectome
is going to be simplified if we can see
some parts of it
that um
are repeated and so we don't have to
decipher the connectivity in all of them
we can recognize units and put them
together and build up
with building blocks that way
so that's the only question i have uh so
thank you very much for listening uh
it's been fun to present this today and
i hope that it's been
enlightening to those of you who who
heard this talk thanks very much
you